[Musica]
no ecco adesso arriva il prof ci fa lo
spiegone di politica poi che noia che
schifo
quando sono stato invitato qui circa tre
mesi fa ho pensato ma si va ad una cosa
interessante il ted mi piace una bella
sfida
poi potrò parlare della break sit in
fondo ho curato da poco un volume su
quel tema breve tempo lo avete sentito
anche voi eri theresa may a firenze e
quindi avevo trovato il mio argomento mi
son detto vai tranquillo ai l'estate
davanti ci penserai il giorno dopo vado
a fare una visita medica dall'oculista
il quale mi fa come dare e io ho subito
un impressione un po strana un po lo
ricorderete forse il film il medico
della mutua guido tersilli dentro un
paziente dall'altra parte ladra ecco
come ha fatto così cosa fai mai visto
prima è il medico cosa baia io insegno
scienza politica o questo esce fila di
pazienti in attesa e disse lui insegna
la politica potete immaginarvi cos'è la
politica per te questo sempre il medico
al paziente che aspettava schifo brutto
ecc
allora io mi sono detto no adesso devo
provare a fare qualcosa di più devo
provare a metterci dentro la break sitma
a fare uno sforzo maggiore che mi ha
portato tra l'altro a cambiare un po
anche il titolo non so se si potesse ma
l'ho fatto e quello di cui voglio
parlare c'entra con la brad smith perché
uno dei processi ai quali assistiamo
negli ultimi nell'ultimo anno e mezzo
della vittoria del populismo la crisi
politica
e allora l'idea che vorrei portarvi oggi
in questi quattordici minuti e mezzi che
mi rimangono prima di entrare nella zona
rossa del tempo non in questa in cui
sono ora è proprio legata al tentativo
di mettere insieme politica e tempo
senza spero annoiarvi e allora siccome
mi piacciono le sfide ho scelto un
titolo abbastanza impegnativo per
rimanere nel mondo del cinema sembra di
avere sesso bugie e videotape oppure 4
matrimonio funerale e il mio titolo tre
tempi quattro libri e un triangolo e per
chi vuole anche
la papua nuova guinea e il mio argomento
in realtà si può riassumere nella
questione dei tre tempi
in sostanza noi noi tutti tendiamo a
valutare ciò che succede nel nostro
periodo al periodo della crisi come
dicevamo prima con degli occhiali
sfocati e possa tornare ancora
l'oculista perché non teniamo in
considerazione che la politica è
un'attività umana e che quando
giudichiamo ciò che succede nella
politica dobbiamo andare a seguire
diversi tempi quindi io non ho una
risposta su cosa farei su marte poi col
40 minuti in più ma la mia risposta
estiva è stata cercare di impegnare un
po di tempo per capire il rapporto tra
politica e tempo e allora ci sono tre
tempi secondo me importanti nella
politica che sono quella della
definizione di venticinque secoli fa di
aristotele dell'uomo come animale
politico e in questa definizione sono
importanti sia il sostantivo sia
l'aggettivo l'idea che noi tendiamo
tutti alla socialità ma che siamo anche
degli animali e come tutti gli animali
abbiamo degli istinti che a volte
prevalgono sulla ragione quando noi
difendiamo il nostro gruppo la nostra
famiglia la nostra tribù
il secondo tempo è quello della
democrazia come sapete tutti democrazia
è un concetto la cui etimologia risale
anch'esso alla grecia antica ma la
democrazia di oggi e la democrazia
rappresentativa e da un tempo diverso
rispetto a quello della democrazia
ateniese diciamo quindi sostanzialmente
l'ultimo secolo anche qui vi risparmio
tutte le definizioni ma è importante
perché noi non riusciamo a proiettare
indietro quelli che sono i tempi della
politica non riusciamo a capire cosa
succede oggi perché spesso ci fermiamo a
volte addirittura a dopo il 1945 quindi
gli ultimi 70 anni quando l'idea
quantomeno di democrazia si diffonde nel
mondo
l'ultimo tempo come accennavo è quello
della crisi quello del sorgere del
populismo e i due fenomeni del 2016 di
conoscete tutti
prima referendum sulla brigitte poi la
vittoria di donald trump negli stati
uniti
allora secondo me questi tempi si
possono anche un po vedere con un
parallelo se volete un po forzato anche
lì
torno alla medicina all'anatomia come
tre organi del nostro corpo
in sostanza il nostro cervello si è
evoluto nel corso dei millenni ma noi
condividiamo ancora oggi gli esperti di
scienza ce lo dicono il 99 per cento del
nostro patrimonio genetico con gli
scimpanzè quindi abbiamo una parte
animale molto forte al nostro interno e
quindi qui il cervello può essere
diciamo le origini antiche della
politica
il cuore è quello che batte per la
democrazia nelle nostre società tutti
cerchiamo di difendere quel poco o tanto
di democrazia che abbiamo e anche di
esportarla spesso senza successo
ma tant'è e infine c'è la crisi la crisi
se volete potete associarla al fegato
allo stomaco alla capacità di resistere
alla perdita di lavoro a qualcosa che
non ci piace
e allora questi tre tempi vanno spesso
intrecciati in modo molto complesso
all'interno di ciò che noi facciamo in
politica e per aiutare spiegarvi meglio
come questo avviene
mi rifaccio ai quattro libri che mi sono
sembrate interessanti per dare questa
lettura della politica e del tempo è il
primo libro è quello che è stato scritto
da un fisico italiano che lavora in
francia forse qualcuno di voi l'ha letto
adesso non vede chi ha letto alzi la
mano l'ordine del tempo di carlo rovelli
non vedo niente assolutamente va beh
qualcuno lo avrà letto perché un libro
che ha fatto un certo successo ed al
quale io inesperto totale in fisica ho
capito che in realtà non è non occorre
andare su marte per avere una durata
diversa del tempo ma basta anche
misurare il tempo tra la pianura e la e
la montagna
ho anche avuto due reazioni opposte
leggendo questo libro da una parte mi
sono scoraggiato detto non sarò mai in
grado di scrivere qualcosa di simile
nemmeno a 90 anni
sull'ordine della politica semmai si
potrà scrivere un libro accurato su
questo tema ma dall'altra mi ha
stimolato a cercare una traccia per
spiegare meglio quello che mi stava
venendo in mente a proposito di tempo e
politica e allora il secondo libro è un
libro di uno psicologo sociale americano
anche lui ha fatto
molto visto si chiama le menti tribali e
torna al concetto di cui parlavo prima
all'idea che noi abbiamo soprattutto noi
uomini noi tutti abbiamo delle reazioni
istintive quando percepiamo una minaccia
un pericolo che sia reale o meno quello
che importa in realtà è la nostra
percezione e jonathan ed ha scritto
questo libro molto interessante in cui
spiega appunto quali sono le nostre
reazioni a fenomeni che ci spaventano e
che non c è che ci mettono in difficoltà
in qualche modo questo mi permette di
arrivare a cercare di spiegare gli
eventi di cui vi parlavo prima e cioè
trump e soprattutto da bradley
e qui entra in campo il terzo libro
scritto da un giornalista politico
britannico david drive che presenta
questa tesi a mio parere molto
interessante
the road somewhere si chiama e lui dice
in sostanza che oggi il conflitto
politico spesso trascende destra e
sinistra ed è tra i favorevoli ei
contrari alla globalizzazione abbiamo
sentito pochi minuti fa carlos dire io
mi sento un cittadino del mondo è quello
che dice guidate proprio questo che
nelle nostre società possiamo dividere i
due gruppi quelli che lui chiama gli
anywhere cioè che si sentono a proprio
che si sentono magari in primo luogo
italiani e portoghesi spagnoli quello
che volete ma si sentono a proprio agio
con le dinamiche della globalizzazione
invece samuel coloro che sviluppano una
identità territoriale che percepiscono
anche un timore una paura rispetto a
queste dinamiche di apertura della
globalizzazione non necessariamente
queste persone sono tutte e xenofobe
razziste anzi dice goodhart spesso è una
componente un nocciolo duro di questi
somewhere coloro che sono veramente e
razzisti però ciò che è avvenuto nelle
nostre società è che mentre nelle élite
politiche si restringeva il gruppo dei
somewhere diciamo in molte società non
in tutte nella popolazione si allargava
invece in in maniera importante
questo è uno dei delle spiegazioni che
sono state fornite quantomeno per
valutare ciò che è successo con il
referendum sulla breve sit la paura
degli immigrati
e qui arrivò all'ultimo volume forse
questo autore qualcuno di voi lo ha
sentito perché 30 anni fa al crollo del
muro di berlino
francis fukuyama divenne famoso per una
tesi un po ardita e il suo libro si
chiamava la fine della storia è l'ultimo
uomo e in questo libro fukuyama
sosteneva che col crollo del comunismo
la liberaldemocrazia si sarebbe diffusa
nel mondo
sappiamo quello che purtroppo è successo
dopo e quindi però il nostro autore non
si è dato per vinto ha scritto aderirvi
e qui lo ritroviamo proprio con
l'origine dell'ordine politico e un
tentativo di spiegare qual è
l'importanza del tempo nel costruire una
società ha un sistema politico che
funzioni e allora fukuyama ci propone
tre aspetti mi rendo conto che ho sempre
lo spiegone che mi aleggia sopra quindi
non devono esagerare però nel leggere
fukuyama mi sono detto questo è
interessante e proviamo a proporlo e ho
aggiunto una cosa mia questo se volete
al triangolo di baldini fu curiamo forse
meglio fukuyama baldini perché poi lui
ci ha messo la sostanza io ci ho messo
la forma e fukuyama dice che per un
sistema per far funzionare un sistema
politico occorrono tre cose 1 stato
costruito con un'amministrazione che sia
però impersonale torniamo al tema della
famiglia del clan della tribù per
costruire uno stato efficiente occorre
reclutare no nel proprio cugino fratello
moglie nei posti chiave
ma appunto un processo un procedimento
meritocratico e impersonale poi occorre
un meccanismo di certezza del diritto
se volete quello che troviamo anche se
purtroppo spesso non è rispettato nei
nostri parlamenti la legge è uguale per
tutti non solo per noi cittadini comuni
ma anche per i potenti coloro che
ricoprono cariche e infine un meccanismo
di accountability cioè rendiconto chi
sta al potere deve rendere conto di ciò
che fa e noi cittadini possiamo decidere
se confermarlo o meno nel suo ruolo
ora tutto questo sembra facile in realtà
e complessissimo ci sono società nelle
quali esiste una sola di queste
componenti e che però non sono
democratiche pensate alla cina la cina
uno degli stati più forti secondo
fukuyama è il paese in cui in realtà lo
stato nasce per la potenza della
dinastia qing che costruisce
all'amministrazione per la prima volta
nel ii secolo avanti cristo e altri
stati che ieri e che invece riescono più
o meno miracolosamente a rispettare un
po questi tre vertici del triangolo e a
porli anche in equilibrio tra di loro
che è il vero segreto della della
politica e qui il paese che troviamo al
centro del triangolare danimarca la
danimarca
secondo molti ranking internazionali di
qualità della democrazia di
soddisfazione della vita è al top è però
questo lo sappiamo anche se 500 anni fa
ci dicevano che c'è del marcio in
danimarca e per alcuni aspetti ce n'è
anche oggi nel senso che non esiste
l'eldorado il paese il paradiso in terra
e in danimarca però esiste un rispetto
un equilibrio tra questi criteri
e cosa c'entra tutto questo voi direte
con la brigitte c'entra perché la gran
bretagna nella sequenza dello sviluppo
di questi tre vertici dei triangoli ha
seguito una traiettoria molto diversa
rispetto a quello degli altri paesi
europei si sono sviluppati prima certo
vertice rispetto all'altro anche qui e
vi risparmio i dettagli ma
l'appartenenza britannica la comunità
poi unione europea è sempre stata
vissuta in maniera sofferta sempre della
gran bretagna sempre stato un partner
riluttante all'interno delle istituzioni
europee
questo 15 torna a far riflettere sui
tempi della politica sul fatto che in
quel paese per primo si è dato di fatto
un reference e ha ottenuto il referendum
per uscire dall'unione europea
l'esito è stato poi quello che sappiamo
ora non sappiamo cosa succederà del
processo e questo è uno dei motivi per
cui non ne ho voluto parlare tanto ma
sappiamo che quel processo quando ho
cercato di mostrare con questo con
questa nuova figura impatta su tutti gli
elementi dell'ordine politico di quel
paese
quindi la lezione che ci arriva da
questo caso quantomeno è proprio legata
a ciò che dicevo all'inizio l'idea cioè
che i nostri atteggiamenti di tutti noi
sono spesso legati a emozioni a
razionalità a elementi che sono
stratificati nel tempo e se questo non
non vi avesse ancora convinto allora ti
faccio fare un salto nello spazio
riporto in papua nuova guinea paese che
conosco ma dove non sono mai stato
magari qualche fortunato tra di voi ci è
andato in vacanza quindi dall'altra
parte della terra
noi abbiamo una società un sistema
politico in cui ancora oggi nel 2017
convivono persone che parlano 900 lingue
diverse
ora la lingua era un elemento
fondamentale per creare una comunità e
lì non si parla non si capiscono a poche
decine di chilometri distanza non stiamo
parlando di rodigini con ferraresi
modenesi ma gente che proprio non si
capisce e lì in qualche modo il tempo
sembra essersi fermato perché ancora
oggi si vota per tribù i famosi van top
e non solo ma si cerca anche si vota
questa è un'idea diffusa all'interno di
quella società per un big man che come
sapete si è spesso cercato anche in
altre società a noi più vicini
ora è tutto questo ci dice che
l'intreccio spazio tempo e complesso che
la politica anche se non è facile potrà
essere noiosa schifosa come detto
all'inizio come molti la ritengono ma
merita comunque di essere studiata
quantomeno per capirla e lo sforzo va in
quella direzione
per cui è il fatto che gli eventi del
2016 drive the la vittoria di trump
siano eventi episodici o invece
destinati a essere i primi due di altri
eventi di quel tipo
ovviamente anche quella cosa lì
se sarà così ce lo potrà dire solo il
tempo classico
[Applauso]